T
ACTOR HENRY CAVILL REVEALED TO
HIS FANS AND WHAT'S BEHIND HIS
DECISION.
>>> THERE SEEMS TO BE SOMETHING
MISSING FROM THE AMERICAN
WORKFORCE.
MEN ARE MISSING.
NEW DATA SHOWS MORE MEN ARE OUT,
MORE WOMEN ARE IN.
MANY OF THEM WORKING IN FIELDS
TRADITIONALLY DOMINATED BY GUYS.
WHAT'S BEHIND ALL OF THIS?
VANESSA, WHAT'S UP?
WHY ARE THE LADIES TAKING OVER
AND THE MEN BACKING OUT, IS THIS
A GOOD THING?
>> IT'S A GOOD THING AND THERE'S
SOME BAD TO IT.
BUT OVERALL DURING THE PANDEMIC
WE LOST SO MANY JOBS BUT WHAT
HAPPENED IS BOTH MEN AND WOMEN
HAVE GAINED ALL OF THE JOBS BACK
THAT THEY LOST DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
HOWEVER, WE ARE SEEING SOMETHING
VERY INTERESTING HAPPENING WITH
MIDDLE AGED MEN AND WOMEN, FEWER
MEN IN THE LABOR MARKET, MORE
WOMEN.
WHAT'S BEHIND THE TREND?
WE SET OUT TO FIND OUT.
>> GOOD MORNING, WINSTON, LET'S
START THE DAY.
>> IT'S A TYPICAL DAY, 17 MONTH
OLD WINSTON IS UP AND DAVID AND
ALLISON ARE GETTING READY FOR
WORK.
THERE'S PLAY, AND THEN THE
MORNING GOOD-BYES.
THEY'RE OFF TO WORK, ALISYN A
FAMILY PHYSICIAN AND DAVID AN
INSURANCE UNDERWRITER NOW AN
AT-HOME DAD.
>> CARING FOR WINSTON, TENDING
TO THE HOUSE, PLAYING WITH HIM,
ALL OF THAT COMES FIRST.
>> Reporter: LAST YEAR THEY MADE
A LIFE CHANGE.
>> WE MADE THAT DECISION TO HAVE
ME STAY HOME.
>> Reporter: DAVID QUIT HIS JOB
TO TAKE CARE OF WINSTON FULL
TIME.
>> WE'RE HAPPY.
>> Reporter: MORE MEN AGES 30 TO
44 HAVE BEEN DROPPING OUT OF THE
WORKFORCE.
THE LABOR FORCE PARTICIPATION
RATE FOR MEN IN THAT AGE GROUP
IS LOWER THAN IT WAS
PRE-PANDEMIC.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S A SECRET
THAT MANY OF US RETHOUGHT OUR
WHOLE WORK LIFE BALANCE, WHAT
WERE WE DOING, WHO'S RAISING THE
KIDS?
HOW DO WE WANT OUR FAMILY TO
WORK?
>> Reporter: AND MORE WOMEN IN
RECENT MONTHS AGES 30 TO 44 ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THE LABOR FORCE
AND AT A HIGHER RATE THAN
PRE-PANDEMIC ACCORDING TO LABOR
DEPARTMENT DATA.
AND THEY'RE MOVING INTO MORE
MALE DOMINATED INDUSTRIES.
>> THE FEARS OF A SHECESSION WAS
UNFOUNDED, WOMEN ARE RETURNING
AND IT'S COMMON TO SEE WOMEN
WITH PROJECT MANAGEMENT ROLES OR
MANAGEMENT POSITIONS WITHIN
CONSTRUCTION.
>> Reporter: WOMEN LIKE AVA.
>> I KNEW I WANTED TO WORK IN
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT.
>> Reporter: SHE JOINED TWO
YEARS AGO AS A PROJECT ENGINEER.
TODAY WOMEN MAKE UP 14% OF THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY BUT IT'S
THE HIGHEST ON RECORD.
>> I THINK IT WAS DEFINITELY
INTIMIDATING.
MY KNOWLEDGE OF THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY WAS THAT IT WAS PRETTY
HEAVY AND MALE DOMINATED.
BUT THE MORE THAT I STARTED
WORKING IN THE INDUSTRY AND THE
MORE PEOPLE I CAME INTO CONTACT
WITH, I THINK I REALIZED QUICKLY
PRETTY ON THERE'S A PLACE FOR
EVERYONE IN CONSTRUCTION.
>> Reporter: DO YOU SEE THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AS WHERE
YOU WANT TO BUILD YOUR CAREER?
>> DEFINITELY.
>> Reporter: EARLY NEXT YEAR,
THEY'LL WELCOME BABY NUMBER TWO,
ANOTHER BOY.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN DAVID IS
CLOSING THE DOOR ON REJOINING
THE WORKFORCE ONE DAY.
>> I WON'T SAY I'M OUT OF THE
WORKFORCE 100%, RETIRED, WHAT
HAVE YOU.
BUT FOR THE TIME BEING WE WANT
TO GIVE OUR SECOND INFANT SON
THE SAME THING WE GAVE TO OUR
FIRST, AND THAT IS A PARENT
WHO'S ABLE TO GIVE THEM 100%.
>> Reporter: NOW DAVID'S REASON
FOR LEAVING THE LABOR FORCE IS
BECAUSE HE WANTED TO STAY HOME
WITH HIS SON AND TAKE CARE OF
HIM.
BUT THAT'S A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
MEN AND WHY THEY'RE LEAVING THE
LABOR FORCE.
ECONOMISTS SAY A LOT OF IT HAVE
TO DO WITH SOME MEN OUT ON
DISABILITY, MENTAL HEALTH
REASONS, INCARCERATION BUT AS
WE'VE SEEN IN THE PIECE WOMEN
STEPPING INTO MORE
MALE-DOMINATED INDUSTRIES, WOMEN
ARE LEAVING FEMALE-DOMINATED
INDUSTRIES LIKE TEACHING AND
NURSING SO WE NEED MEN TO STEP
INTO THOSE ROLES.
THE PANDEMIC CHANGED THE WAY WE
WORK BUT IT ALSO CHANGED WHAT
PEOPLE ARE WILLING TO DO FOR
WORK.
IT'S AN INTERESTING TIME COMING
OUT OF THE PANDEMIC IN THE LABOR
MARKET RIGHT NOW.
>> I THINK IT'S GOOD.
LISTEN, BARRING THE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND ALL THAT.
BUT I THINK IT'S GOOD BECAUSE
IT'S A RESET.
THE ROLES THAT TRADITIONALLY YOU
THOUGHT WERE MALE/FEMALE
SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN THAT WAY,
BUT IT IS WHAT IT IS.
THERE SHOULD BE MORE MALE
TEACHERS, THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF
MALE TEACHERS I THINK IT HELPS
WITH THE PAY GAP, EQUITY, WOMEN
SWITCHING IT'LL HELP WITH THAT.
BUT ALSO POPPY AS YOU KNOW, I
TOLD YOU COVID HAD A LOT TO DO
WITH IT.
BUT YOU GET TO A CERTAIN POINT
IN LIFE WHERE YOU SAY IT'S NOT
ABOUT THE JOB, YOU WANT TO BE
WITH YOUR FAMILY.
AND AT THIS POINT WHERE I'M
ABOUT TO GET MARRIED, IF WE HAD
KIDS I WOULD STEP BACK.
>> HE WAS SAYING THIS IN YOUR
PIECE.
I SAID WAIT UNTIL YOU HAVE KIDS
BECAUSE IT'S MORE FULFILLING, IN
CERTAIN WAYS, BUT HARDER TO BE
AT HOME.
I HAVE THE MOST RESPECT FOR WHAT
I THINK IS THE MOST
UNDERAPPRECIATED JOB IN AMERICA,
WHICH IS TO BE A STAY-AT-HOME
PARENT.
LIKE YOUR SISTER HAS RAISED
TWINS, IT'S VERY, VERY HARD, BUT
IT IS EVERYTHING.
>> AND DAVID SAID THEY BOTH GO
TO WORK, SHE GOES TO HIS JOB AND
HE GOES TO WORK TAKING CARE OF
WINSTON.
>> THERE ARE STUDIES THAT SHOW
THAT MEN BEING INVOLVED WITH
THEIR CHILDREN, WHICH IS WHY
PATERNITY LEAVE IS SO IMPORTANT,
ARE MORE CONNECTED TO THEIR
CHILD THROUGH THE WHOLE LIFE.
>> I NEED TO AFFORD SOMEONE TO
HELP ME CHANGE THE DIAPERS.
>> YOU'RE FINE AND YOU SHOULD
CHANGE YOUR OWN DIAPERS.
I DON'T EVER WANT TO HEAR THAT
BEGIN.
>> YOU CAN DO IT.
YOU GOT IT.
>> CLEANING UP DOGGY ACCIDENTS
THAT'S ENOUGH.
CHANGING DIAPERS, I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THAT